à new york l'emplacement même des deux
tours de manhattan est devenu un site
touristique entre guillemets avec son
inévitable cortège de marchands de
souvenirs qui ne sont pas toujours du
meilleur goût stéphane breitner olivier
robert pour visiter ground zero quelques
minutes suffisent une allée de 50 mètres
bordée d'un grillage ici vingt mille
curieux s'entassent tous les jours là vu
un trou de la taille de trois terrains
de football
des grues et des ouvriers au travail
si vous voulez des explications andres
arango vous fera faire le tour du site
confortablement assis dans un pousse
pousse pour 60 dollars de l'heure vous
saurez tout sur la tragédie du 11
septembre et à ce moment là la poussière
s'est engouffré ça a fait boum
partout il y en avait partout surtout
les bulls avec une dizaine de visites
par jour l'affairé rentable et ils en
profitent sans état d'âme l'arborent
aweys est aussi une attraction
touristique même s'il ya eu plus d'un
millier de morts
la curiosité des gens les amène ici
c'est naturel c'est ce qu'il se passe
quand il y autant de touristes ça me
paraît normal d'essayer d'en profiter
pour gagner de l'argent
andres arango n'est pas le seul en
profiter à grande 0 impossible de louper
les étalages bull à 20 dollars un album
de photos fait à la va-vite 10 dollars
tee-shirts et autres gadgets devrait
rapporter plusieurs dizaines de millions
de dollars cette année
qobuz
c'est comme les autres business vous
voyez parfois ceux qui ont perdu des
proches sont agressifs avec moi mais il
nous faut pas y penser parce que le but
principal
c'est bien de faire de l'argent beaucoup
dénoncent cet argent fait sur le dos des
morts principalement les familles de
victimes anthony martinez qui a perdu
l'un de ses amis pompiers voudrait voir
disparaître tous ces vendeurs
franchement ils pourraient vendre
ailleurs tous ces souvenirs plutôt
qu'ici dans ces rues où tant de gens
sont morts
ils ne sont là que pour profiter de
cette tragédie et se faire le plus
d'argent possible
4 millions de visiteurs auront vu grande
zéro cette année impossible à new york
de se passer d'une telle manne de
dollars la mairie a donc décidé de
laisser faire